we have rightt with us now he is the
hundredth 909 thwa mayor that said he's
been around a long time of new york bill
de blasio
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you're from the greatest city in
the world is that correct that is
exactly right you know I lived in your
city twice and I can we missed you
across the river I liked a lot of things
about if I never liked that we're the
greatest city in the world big you know
what because it makes everybody else
feel like what's wrong with us why could
it be just the greatest city for New
Yorkers why do you have to be the
greatest city in the world do big were
bold we believe in ourselves but that
doesn't mean we can't love everyone else
this doesn't mean we can't love this not
Trump elected okay
so you are thinking of running I'm not
ruling it out not ruling it out
it does it scare you that there's
already so many people of this field
it's a very crowded field
no it's democracy it's people with a lot
of different experiences views people
have a lot of different backgrounds it's
actually the Democratic Party at its
best I agree there's something good
going on here you know when it was the
power brokers deciding who had a shot
and who didn't that's when we should
have been upset this is actual open
democracy it's ball game I know but I'm
not running for president you might be
that's what I'm saying for you what you
got to ask yourself why don't I got that
the rest of these people don't got what
do you got they don't have I'm not here
to compare against others but I'll say
what I'm doing in my city because I
think that's the important point we
believe in New York City that we have to
be bold about progressive solutions that
we have to stop being apologetic I'm
actually quite sick of Democrats who are
afraid to be Democrats who are afraid to
be bold and progressive so for example
we
last month I said let's stop waiting for
the things we should get from Washington
like Medicare for All single-payer
health insurance let's stop waiting
let's guarantee health care for every
New Yorker we're doing that now every
New Yorker will have a right to health
care but you know I mean look at some of
the red state Democrats who win there's
not many people like sherrod Brown right
Amy Klobuchar Claire McCaskill until
recently Joe Manchin in West Virginia
they wouldn't say something like that I
don't think would they maybe they
wouldn't have as lay all over the
country doesn't the secret to winning
for the Democrat is you have to the
progressives in the centrist and you
have to somehow convince both of them
you're talking to both of them I think
that is a conventional wisdom we were
all taught and I think it was a lie Wow
the centrist got us nowhere
and by the way when it comes to the 2020
Democratic nomination process centrist
need not apply in my view well the
progressive wing is what's ascendant
right now for a reason because
progressives provide a idea of the
Democratic Party that's truly
identifiable the people will know if you
say we guarantee health care if you say
we're going to ensure that people have a
living wage we're going to address this
madness of the 1% taking all the wealth
and power for themselves people know
which side you're on they can identify
the only reason Donald Trump had its
chance in 2016 was at too many working
Americans didn't know if Hillary Clinton
was on their side she tried to
articulate a vision I want to take that
away from her but people couldn't tell
if she was a part of the elite that had
caused their problems or if she was part
of a process of change what we have to
do as Democrats is be so bold and so
clear that's a mistake we'll another
example in New York City we are going to
pass a law guaranteeing two weeks paid
time off two weeks paid vacation for
every single working New Yorker people
need time for themselves and their
families
because people are working they're
working harder and harder you see what's
happening our society people are working
harder and harder they're getting less
and less for it we have to show people
on their side we're going to do
something about it and this will you
think changed the view of people in the
country at large about Democrats because
just having a D by your name is so toxic
in about half this country that they
stick with a Mad King like Donald Trump
or anybody they will vote for anybody in
at least twenty states if they are
anything but a Democrat why is that why
is the D so toxic okay what did the
Democrats why are they so obnoxious to
people well I think Democrats lost their
way as part of why they're so obnoxious
to people because it used to be the
party of working people was
unquestionably the party of working
people so when you think about the
generations of Democrats where did you
get Social Security from Democrats where
did you get the the 40-hour workweek
from so you didn't have to you know have
to take your whole life and give it over
to work six days seven days a week
Democrats created a lot of the actual
decent benefits in our society the way
of living that people could have a
middle-class lifestyle but then at a
certain point they started being afraid
to pursue the next step and the next
step today in this country too many
people are not living a decent life
working longer and longer getting less
and less back for it paying their taxes
but watching the 1% not pay their fair
share and people are upset about it and
they have a right to be upset about all
right let me ask you about something
that that I care about pot yes are
consistent thank you I like what you
said you said we have to make sure that
those who bore the brunt of past burdens
we're talking about legalizing cannabis
reap the most future benefit that means
that a majority the opportunity
generated in this new industry must go
to people of color so this this is like
like the way the Indians got casinos I
hope it's better than that
I hope we don't yeah it'll be but that's
what you're saying is that we're going
to you know can white people get in this
industry or they're cut off no everyone
a little bit thank you for your
contribution that it's not just about
race it is about an economic reality too
so here's one trying to say for years
and years broken laws sent a huge number
of Americans to jail right most of them
were young people of color yeah and
we've got an industry that hat now is
just licking its chops waiting to come
in and corporatize marijuana to do
exactly what the tobacco industry did
was cigarettes exactly what the
pharmaceutical industry did with things
like oxy cotton and what we need is
legalized marijuana without corporatized
marijuana I don't know about that I
don't think that's possible completely
but I think I like the boldness of this
you're saying this is a great way to do
reparations it's a way to say we had an
injustice right now let's get the very
people who are victims of economic
benefit now that we're on a roll
yes here's where I want to change
challenge you on what a lot of Democrats
are pretty you know suggesting a lot of
big ticket items Medicare for all
they're saying would cost 32 trillion in
ten years and it's always well then
we're gonna tax the rich more you know
that's not gonna pay for a 32 trillion
the rich already paid quite a bit they
should pay more yes okay why don't you
guys ever say we should cut the military
budget in half that's where the money is
that's being wasted the most decoupled
defense the defense contractors from
actually protecting the country okay so
I agree with you that there's a huge
amount of waste in the military budget
and I agree with you that we can find a
lot of money in the military budget but
let me make the bigger point about
taxation there is plenty of money in the
United States of America there's plenty
of money in LA there's plenty of money
in New York City it's just in the wrong
hands that is the reality and that means
taxing the wealthy repealing the Trump
tax cuts and giveaways to the
corporations and the wealthy but look if
you had Medicare for all then average
Americans are not paying their premiums
their co-pays their out-of-pocket
expenses for health care their
deductibles the idea of Medicare for all
is yet tax the wealthy as part of it
but also take away from people all those
other expenses in their lives if you ask
them to contribute then to the costs of
Medicare for all
it actually Nets out in their favor but
yes the military budgets in another
place we can save no because I know what
we're not secure if people in our nation
are not living a decent life that's the
bottom line
you